hallo leute werden heute besuch von lula
lula woher kommst du ich komme aus
brasilien aber ich bin brasilianer um
franzose und wo wohnst du in london
und wie viele sprachen spricht sechs
sprachen
das ist krass und lula was ist dein
beruf
ich bin schauspieler und was fragen wir
heute auf der straße in berlin
wer ist dein lieblingsschauspieler
was für eine passende frage losgeht
würde ich johnny depp sagen auf jeden
fall was gefällt oder die er in seine
schauspielerischen fähigkeiten würde ich
sagen also übrigens auch überzeugend
rüber und wieder sieht man ganz gut aus
auf jeden fall eine vereinigten denn
verein ist sehr sehr gut
ja die spiele möglichst einfach zu haben
ja aber ich habe auch leonardo dicaprio
ist auch ein super schauspieler gehabt
überhaupt mehr und streep sie ist eine
meiner lieblingsschauspieler hin auch
was besonders gefällt ihnen an ihr
sie ist sehr natürlich sie hat kein
problem mit dem altern sie lässt sich
nicht liften also das finde ich sehr gut
und welche rolle von leonardo dicaprio
jennifer aniston habt ihr hat ihr
besonderes
gefallen jennifer aniston friends teil
der serie
wie heißt der film mit leonardo dicaprio
kennst du den wo er denn da spielt er
eine rolle von einem kleinen jungen als
das spielt eine behinderte person also
ja ich spiele keine kein deutscher
schauspieler zum beispiel ein
und welcher ist mein lieblingsfilm habe
ich auch kein mein lieblingsfilm ist
marchetti kirche tätig ist dann habe ich
nicht gesehen und lieblingsschauspieler
demnach danny trejo den der empfehlen
mitgespielt wurde ja ja der mit der
machete die arme und beine ab schlägt
ganz schlecht aber überlegen
ich habe immer bilder aber nicht die
namen ein deutscher schauspieler der
nicht geister mag ich sage auch einen
anderen sagen reich aber deutsche zoll
in deutscher oder amerikanischer bruder
ja ja ein deutscher ist charly hübner
hübner
ich habe das stück so gesehen ja er
spielt den tatort aber auch andere filme
und und ein internationaler oder an ein
englischer spieler den ich mag ist
tiefstes nehmen ja schon längst den
point für mich war das nie der sind aber
die heißen hier der wäre es toll dafür
her sind hier der berühmte film von tom
hanks forrest gump mit der forrest gump
ist ja eine fantastische fehlen mir
gefällt ganz besonders wir diese hohe
gewalt schauspielerisch darstellt wir
halt also wirklich ohne rücksicht auf
verluste mit der machete wütend durch
die die länder zieht und das böse
vernichtet nämlich die drogenkartelle
den mexikanischen drogenkartelle und
auch korrupte politiker er räumt
sozusagen mexiko erst mal richtig auf
und das mag ich halt sehr sehr sparen
also in mexiko ist eigentlich sehr schön
ist dass ich weiß nicht ob das und
aufgeräumt werden muss dabei wenn man
jetzt nur von dem film ausgeht würde ich
sagen ja
wer ist ihre lieblingsschauspieler
lieblingsschauspieler das studio
expertin
es gibt ja ich muss es sein mannsein ist
dabei das hast du nur gesagt weil er
französisch können das sehr sehr guter
schauspieler hin- und in welches team
von isabella berger gefällt ihnen
besonders alle sind muster sind muster
ja nicht die rolle gespielt die es gibt
und wie heißt ja habe ich vergessen
werde heißt es in ganz groß hat ein ganz
langes schmales gesicht und
den mag ich noch
ja ich bin ganz schlecht ich vergessen
mal den namen und empfehlen sie den film
dann für für die zuschauer also empfehle
ich eindeutig allerdings nur personen
über ich weiß nicht 18 ja- oder 21 sogar
weil es ja ganz also wird sehr blutiges
sehen
aber natürlich ist alles nur gespielt
das wissen wir ja weil es ein film ist
deswegen muss man sich auch keine sorgen
machen das stück ja keiner wirklich okay
sein deutscher eigentlich ein schweizer
oder ein deutscher nein nein er ist aus
drei zu hause ist daraus aber er spricht
als wäre ich google war goethe
es gibt you köthe 1 es gibt
you goethe 2 und das gibt you
goethe drei der gefällt mir sehr
welches lied ja der titel sich sehr sehr
lange die filme sind noch viel viel
besser müssen sie sehen und es ist ja
zum lachen später einer schule und die
probleme an deutschen schulen mit
deutschen schülern die nicht lernen
wollen und schon gar nicht deutsch
und das ist ein sehr interessanter film
sah er spielt einen kriminellen der
lehrer wird weil sein geld aus dem
ersten banküberfall ist unter der neu
gebauten schulturnhalle vergraben und
während er tagsüber die schüler
unterrichtet die schlimmste klasse
unterrichtet gräbt der nachts nach
seinem schatz unter der turnhalle ihr
müsst euch den film ansehen das
hinterlässt unbedingt zeigen euren ihren
schülern you wird ja schon sehr
interessant wie bei der beispiele und
welches ziel ist
der lieblings fehlen du redest mit
jemand der ganz selten ins kino geht und
kein flix guckt und noch nicht so viele
serien und so aber
ich habe auch vor dass man als letztes
jahr zwei jahren einen deutschen auch im
deutschen film geguckt hat auch
internationale preise gewonnen hab
vergessen wie er heißt jan krüger oder
nein
die bilder von mir aber ich ja kommt
nicht drauf und einer anderen
lieblingsfilm
würde gerne diese filme anschauen
ja okay ich habe ich habe davon gehört
aber ich habe den film nicht gesehen und
da hat man auch gut oder als kind an
ihre scheffel
weil ich in irland aufgewachsenen
interview ist sehr sehr gut sehr hinter
interesse hat ja danke schön
schönen abend wir sind zurück im
biergarten und jetzt will ich unbedingt
noch von null an wissen wer ist denn
dein lieblingsschauspieler
es gibt viele in großbritannien werde
ich sagen
tom hardy aus den usa meryl streep sehr
beliebt in frankreich vielleicht schon
aber sehr sehr guten schauspieler
wunderbar und aus brasilien vielleicht
fast in jedem land ein lieblingsschüler
fast ja ich weiß wer mein
lieblingsschauspieler ist der ist der er
sitzt neben mir und heißt juli dieses
jahres
[Gelächter]
jetzt stoßen wir darauf an das nicht
zusammen meinen beiden
lieblingsschauspieler nein wir im
biergarten trinken kann und ihr könnt
jetzt noch übungen machen nämlich
interaktive übungen zu dem vokabular und
den ausdrücken aus diesem video
ihr könnt einfach ein tätscheln werden
bei easyjet als mitglied von the german
bekommt ihr jede woche die neuesten
übungen zu unseren videos und natürlich
müsst ihr sie german abonnieren damit
ihr immer
die nachricht erhalten wenn wir ein
neues video haben danke dass du dabei
das wohl aber die wirkungen jetzt noch
fußball ich und wir sehen uns dann
wieder in der nächsten woche tschüss und
bis bald